Oh, codes.
Found one. Oh, okay.
So then this product will diagnose the car engine system.
If you use the function of reading trouble code.
It will read the trouble code and the definition of the trouble code.
If there are engine troubles in the car,
you can run trouble. Oh,
and we only have one trouble code.
Okay, reading codes.
Cylinder 6, misfire detected. Oh my god.
Clean. You can power down the engine to try again.
Boom! Skis.
Are you happy? Uh huh. Maybe
it pays off.
It's on sale
for anybody that having car problems.
This is the little tool we just used from the TikTok shop.
It comes with a little manual to tell you how to use it,
and you just plug it in and boom! You figured our Chanel